hi I'm Rob Riggle actor in such Smash
Hits is 21 Jump Street and the hangover
also star television daily show I want
your support for raw real actors against
web videos in a way it's good that
people can kind of go out there and make
their own thing but also most people are
I mean so yeah there's great videos but
it's free yeah it's free because people
are just pooping it out I mean look I
like seeing a guy get hit in the foot to
like everybody else but no I don't you
know I don't need to see some 14-year
old girl with her laptop open tell me
what clothes she bought or some guy
getting hit in the balls by a wiffle
ball bat something like that and that's
all the internet is bad and disgusting
pornography you know I like that but I
don't want to make it first of all the
screen is so tiny this is meant to be
enjoyed with some high end popcorn and a
$7 coke or their phones you know they're
watching it when they take a don't watch
this when you take people now or say oh
it's all the features in the web but
like come on most people do web series
when they're when they're kind of people
know that they're there they're known as
ask so they're like oh I'll be cute in
this web series so that people don't you
know recognize that I'm a real app stop
web videos
so yeah I hate the Internet